[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time
i'm link and i'm red this week at the
round table of dim lighting we are
getting to know the latest
addition to the neal household
jasper a dog i got another freaking dog
y'all so
we got jade he's here we got sock of the
cat
he's here he's hiding under the table
he's hiding in the wings
and he's he's going to show himself uh
the wings are your lap
yes i can see him right now yeah look i
mean he's very jade like that he's just
in your lap but no
no complaints remember that because
that's that's a big factor in this but
yeah
so um we got three animals in the neil
house now that we got sock of the cat
and jasper the dog and i wanted to
introduce
uh all of you loyal ear biscuit tears
to uh the new wildlife
in the family but why is you see my
phone is like
it's responding like serious listening
constantly what is
what i just stopped talking with it i
don't like the feeling of
being constantly listening to while
having a conversation but what
wanna eventually realize that we're not
talking to it
hurt you mean her no it's it okay
i don't consider i don't give
i think you might need to hit the thing
because that even that glowing orb that
indicates that it's constantly listening
is going to run down your battery
i mean that thing's a battery suck oh
look she look she just took all that
information and then just said
one sec also the entire intro to ear
biscuits let's see
how she responds she's still working
you're saying she now
okay it's still working what's gonna
happen
well i don't even know what she's
working on what are you working on what
do you mean you're working on that
i mean we we we gave it a lot but but
i mean i got yeah something went wrong
that's right
siri let's try let's not try again let's
just keep going how about that so yeah
i'm going to tell you all the
uh all the introductory
struggles and experiences associated
with adding a
third animal and a second dog into the
nil household as we are
slowly creeping out of quarantine you
know us
uh averse to change slowly you're not
reversing new animals though
no we're not which is and we will
discuss the irony in that i did not know
it was going to happen
but it makes total sense in retrospect
but i wanted to start out
just giving you an update and i've got
another
experience that i had on some recent
travels
and i just didn't know if i was going
crazy so i kind of need you to tell me
that well i'm not going to judge whether
or not you're crazy i'm based on one
experience
well you kind of you kind of you can add
it to the yeah i take the whole handles
the whole of your uh everything that i
know about you i said annals and you
said whole
okay that's fine let's get into it
dental hole is not anything
anahol is just a hole where you keep
records
oh okay well let's dig deep and see see
what we can include
so everybody should have one in their
basement we took a family trip
to visit a campus campus was entirely
closed but there's a lot
we could walk around outside because
lily was accepted to this place i'm not
going to say the place
because i don't want to talk about the
place that's not but it's harvard that's
not what this is about but yeah it's
definitely harvard and yale at the same
time right she's going to both of them
she's doing a double major right
between harvard and yale there's a
tunnel that's majoring in both places
and we wanted we wanted to see what this
tunnel was about right you know this
harvard yale tunnel
right yeah the most elite of college
experiences the harvard yale double
major
so we went to uh college
and you know just to kind of
really give a sense of hey this is
happening
you've been accepted here you're most
likely going to go here
let's wrap our minds around the fact
that you are going to college
and we all need to kind of get the
program who was this trip for
well what percentage of like it was
mostly for lilly but yeah i think it's
definitely for
i mean for me and christy it was like
still coming to grips and starting to
prepare emotionally
um and then and you know i think lily's
anxious it's a it's a
it's a huge life change the biggest one
she's ever experienced maybe besides
being born
and um for lincoln i wanted him to be
there to be like okay i'm just
this coming year his junior year he's
going to start he's got to start
thinking about it
got to start thinking about it and gear
up for it and i mean
evidence we weren't going to leave lando
at home alone did you see any evidence
that lincoln was beginning to think
about it
no it's i it's not the type of thing you
see
like i can't look at his face and tell
that like
any wheels are turning i mean
did he what did he say though you know
he's like oh it reminds me
ben told me the other day you know ben's
on camera again for a good mythical
morning
so he's like one of the closest people
to us almost as close as we are to each
other
on set like in between uh
takes or something he was like are you
angry you look angry you kind of leaned
in i was like
no i'm just thinking yeah right when i
think i just look angry
like if i'm really like thinking i think
actually both of us have a tendency to
look angry
while thinking so we've got thinking
angry face yeah when i'm
like i've noticed one of the things i've
noticed this year and being in so many
zoom calls
is that our resting zoom call face both
of us look a little bit
judgy uh-huh like we both we and i would
say even stevie as well
so like when you've got and you know who
are like really engaged with you
because we had some people like pitching
us some things and they're doing all the
talking and i
i think about how i feel when i'm on the
other end of that
pitch process right yeah and
i know that there are people who have a
very warm
sort of resting smiley face an
acceptance face you know accepting face
and i love talking to those people but i
am very well aware that i am not one of
those people
you're not one of those people and
stevie's also not and when you're on
zoom
you can see everybody's face i mean it's
not like being
in a room where you're like you could
see everybody at once and you can be
drawn to the person who looks the
angriest i have to remind myself
and you know it helps to be able to see
yourself i go like
well mallory does a good job she's great
mallory's our head of development
yeah i can see her like if i'm looking
at a person talking i can look over
there and she's got a good
she's got a good listening face she nods
and she smiles she's being supportive
but you might look at us that's right
these guys are having the worst
day of their lives we're not making it
easy but we're not doing it on purpose
so and this is a nice teaser for what
we're going to talk about
in the next episode of ear biscuits
because
we're talking about being on the
receiving end of that rejection
us trying to develop ideas
and we've decided to kind of so next
week we're going to give you this i
didn't mean to make this a teaser right
now but we're going to give you a
download of
all of these ideas and projects in the
traditional realm
for years we've had we've been adding to
a list of projects that we've been
trying to get off the ground
all the things behind the scenes all the
things that people have said no to
all that you know even that we'd never
talk about and so we're going to share
all of those projects with you so if
you're not into a lot of stuff
into dogs or colleges or anything like
that
then next week it's going to be just
about
yeah all the projects that have been
squashed
along with our hearts question mark
might make it a two-parter i don't know
there's a lot to unpack there but we'll
start with just
all the ideas we had we've had um
yeah i've done some digging there let me
see what you remember but anyway back to
the story
so we take a road trip and we're
we got an airbnb because we were going
to stay there the night get out the next
day
spend basically all day walking around
what basically a deserted campus but
still a very cool campus
and i will go ahead and tell you it was
a great experience
i think lily was confirmed more
confirmed in her decision to go there
so i'd say she's at like almost 90
percent now
you know there's she's on a couple of
waiting lists and so
getting those answers and making those
decisions will like make it official but
it was totally worthwhile but i want to
talk about this airbnb
i'm not going to talk about the college
stuff at all because then we stayed
there the next night and and then drove
back
the next day so we stayed there two
nights now uh this is a nice airbnb
it had um four bedrooms
and um so everybody every kid got their
own room they were excited about that
but i knew reading the description and
the
reviews that this was a house that
it was a permanent residence of the
family that lived there
uh a couple and their two sons into the
airbnb
if they like go out of town or something
well apparently
i know i i think they're i actually
think i well i don't
i have relatives who who have done that
okay who airbnb their house when they
go on vacation why not you know you make
a little scratch
i mean i've i've stayed at a lot of
airbnbs
so i have a lot to compare it to but
i didn't think anything of the fact that
this was a permanent residence until we
get there
and there's i mean it's not like they're
everywhere but there are pictures
of the family and there are personal
effects
there's a couple of like grandparent
pictures and then
like in the pantry there's like a clean
shelf and then above it there's like a
shelf full of stuff that says
do not do not eat do not touch and there
was some cereal there and boy i had a
difficult time
i was very excited i should put that in
a cage um
they did let us use their coffee but
still i wasn't thinking too much about
it
you know that night after we watch um
survivor
yeah can no matter where we are on the
planet if it's
if it's if the sun's gone down the nils
have to watch survivor
i'm tucking lando into bed and uh
christy comes in there and we're like
tucking them into bed and it's a
it's a bunk bed room and apparently
these boys it's the boys room that they
share
and lando just looks concerned
and so i'm like buddy what's going on he
was like well
you know people live here i you know
this is
this is this is somebody's room
you know i i feel kind of weird about it
and then he said
i feel like elias is here with me
and i'm like i'm like you know this
boy's name this is like the beginning of
a horror movie i know i was like
please tell me he is not visible to you
and speaking to you right now how did he
get his name
there's like on the front door it's like
elias and whatever his brother's name is
room it like says it
and then it's like got all of their
books toys and all this stuff
was there elias and toby
it's creepier than only elias is there i
know he just had his elias which is a
perfect
horror movie name and when he said that
elias i kind of looked at christie and i
was like i knew my mission
was to just blow it off but i couldn't
help but acknowledge within my own self
that when he said that it kind of
creeped me out
so i'm like listen when you everywhere
we've stayed
people have stayed there like a typical
airbnb
like a hotel i mean every day there's
somebody new staying there every week
there's somebody new staying there
you're yeah you're sleeping in elias's
bed
that's the difference there's but going
down that spirit
is much more present in the place where
he he lives you're feeling lando's vibes
first of all that whole track that i was
on didn't help because it's like oh my
gosh you mean all the other places i've
been
there's been like hundreds and thousands
of people that have slept there
and he didn't know what to be more
disturbed about and as i was saying it
come to think of it neither did i you
haven't thought about this but then as
much as you enjoy
airbnbs i don't like to think about you
know people talk about the black light
of it all especially at hotels but i
have a higher trust in airbnbs it's a
different type of traffic that's that's
your mistake because i don't i don't
want to hear it the nanny cams
i mean there's hidden cameras in there
all air and bbbs
no okay that for legal reasons i can't
say that there are
there has to be hidden cameras that
can't be legal in
of course it's not legal it's highly
illegal and you can get to a lot of
trouble for it
but i'm just saying that people people
are nuts man do you think about that
when you stay at an airbnb
uh yeah i go into you look for cameras i
assume that i'm being recorded when i'm
in teddy bears where one
eyeball is a lot darker than the other
it's never it's never
that uh obvious i just assume i'm being
recorded you've found
a camera you've never found no i just
assume i'm being recorded and i act like
i'm on a reality show so sometimes
there's a little
i get a little bit angry about something
but it's just for it's just for the
camera okay as long as there's a
resolution at the end of the 22 minutes
right especially during certain
activities i really think about the
cameras no
you got to get the angles right so i
didn't know what to say to
help him feel better so i just was like
hey it's no big deal
and he's in it and like his last words
as i was leaving
the room were i feel like elias is
sleeping with me
and i was like don't put it like that
he but he was also and so he was but he
was kind of messing with you a little
bit he
he thought it was funny right he wasn't
really scared no this is coming from a
place of this is what he's thinking
but based on me and chris's reactions he
did kind of cool off a little bit he did
sleep in the bed and he was
he ended up being fine but i went
downstairs
and i ended up watching some stuff with
christy and then she goes to bed and i'm
the only one downstairs
all of our bedrooms are upstairs and
then
i'm turning off the lights and getting
ready to head upstairs i go to the front
door and i lock it
and then to the right of the front door
uh as i'm walking back there's another
door that's closed
owner's owner's closet well and then i
realized
this is not a closet this is this is the
door to their garage
we couldn't park in the garage we had to
walk around it to the front door but
there's a door right there
and with all the lights off i noticed
something i hadn't seen before
there was light spilling out from the
bottom
and a little bit of the sides up the
sides
of this door that means there's a light
on on the other side of the door
exactly there's a light on in this
garage
okay and i stood there
and i realized i was kind of getting
freaked out
now you've seen parasite yeah i started
to think
that the family was in the garage
because i've been wondering
i knew the family was still in town
because i was in i was in contact
with uh the wife do you think elias
his mom and dad and his little brother
toby or whatever his name is
go into the garage and then let a family
of five stay in their house
yeah and i think that they're all seems
i think they're implausible i
i was just standing there in the dark
with the light spilling around the edge
of the door
staring at the doorknob and thinking
elias and his family are huddled in that
garage
just trying to make some extra scratch
waiting for us to leave and they're
listening
to all of our conversations i mean it's
like the
door but worse and then i
i make up my mind and i slowly
should open it quickly reach for
the knob i grab the knob
and i turn it
it's locked yeah because they're in
they've locked themselves in there yeah
yeah they're in there huddled in the
circle and i jostled it a few more times
and then i just like stood back and i
was like oh now they know i
i'm on to them and i just
and i just went upstairs and went to bed
end of story but they're in there
pooping in buckets
i know it's like i mean do they have
another it's a permanent resident do
they have another house in town
i know they were still in town because i
know they came back
when we left because of i got a message
after checkout pretty quickly from her
and i'm pretty sure it was her
they probably have another family that
they
can go and stay with because you know
the town that they're in is a town that
people would want to or they could be in
the garage
uh they're not in the garage i i can
safely say that but you were being
filmed
for sure but the laughs on them because
but other than
now i'm exporting it for a podcast but
other than the
uh i mean assuming let's just assume
that they're not in the garage and they
just left the light on in the garage
which is probably the more likely thing
do you feel differently about staying in
is there are there other differences but
by staying in somebody's house that is a
designated airbnb where it's not a
problem
got in my head man i am definitely uh
team not permanent residents airbnb i
definitely think that's right
because you kind of want to make a space
your own but i would say that maybe
every 10th time
yeah you stay in an airbnb you should
stay in one that's a permanent residence
because
to me a lot of you know you know me i
think a lot about the apocalypse and i
think about what it's going to be like
to just go into people's homes
after the world oh you're into this and
like
just assume their life you're like
rustling through their books i mean
in the bedroom are you looking through
their drawers
like chrissy and i slept in their bed
yeah but
again like you said earlier in a hotel
bed you're sleeping in a bed
it's better you're sleeping in a bed
that so many other people have slept in
so many people and people do things i
never thought about this stuff people's
land
falls in hotel beds that they won't do
in their own business oh
yeah yeah that's right yeah they're like
i can tell you that this is a hotel bed
personal experience we don't have to
worry we don't have to worry about
breaking this bed
what if what have you done uh i can't i
mean you have to watch some of the tapes
that people have
made of me that are somewhere on some
website
the airbnb files it's called
anilhole.com oh gosh
oh gosh i mean i i just
so i mean i definitely felt like i was
under more scrutiny to take good care of
their house
but christy had an opposite effect when
we were leaving uh she was gonna miss it
she went to a local plant shop
and she bought a plant and gave it and
left it
with a with a note because you know
there's somebody who's going to
experience it
and she had gotten to know him yeah
right yeah
it's not just it's not just people
passing
passing through it's people that like
this is their i mean she was
wearing space the wife's underwear she
like went through her drawer and she was
like
oh should i get something like this so
they did what about something
so they didn't have any locks on their
underwear drawers
nope now because i i recently stayed at
an airbnb
and there was one there were two doors
one closet that was locked yeah there's
always the closet this left and then a
weird handleless hingeless door
in the bathroom actually in the bathroom
in the toilet closet
like they have one of those bathrooms
yeah it just has a little toilet room oh
wow another room from in there and then
there was a little room in there and it
said it had they had done a lot of
labeling
yep owner's private closet
and they were in there i think it made
us the owner's closet private
was there live emitting from the crowd
they were squat squatting in there but i
will say uh
they came out once you went to sleep i
could not get into it
despite trying and it wasn't because i
wanted to get in and find
and get into the owner's private closet
yeah it was that there wasn't a handle
and i was like well how do they get into
this closet like do i push on it do i
pull on it do you need a crowbar
i didn't do any damage to it but while
taking you got frustrated
while doing a bm uh which
i was probably i was probably on the pot
for seven to eight minutes which i know
is more than you'd really need
but i spent a lot of time trying to
while my
pants were completely around my ankles
try to get into this
private closet it was a short closet
oh yeah i would have had to they're they
were really hungry
but i was already squatting so if i
hadn't gotten it open i would have just
rolled off the toilet right
right into the into the closet
i mean the one my biggest critique
besides all of the critiques directed
toward lando who
basically ruined my trip um
are they that there was a squeegee in
the shower
now much respect i i don't do i don't we
don't have that but
i've certainly thought about it but to
leave a squeegee out for your guests to
use is a bit much that's a bit
heavy-handed
because here i am squeegeeing somebody
else's shower
so you took the glass door well yeah it
was there i felt like i had to
i felt like i had to do the squeegee you
know it's like i was was it hanging on
something or was it sitting in the
shower it was propped up on the floor of
the shower
against the door yeah that's offensive
yeah it's a bit they should have taken
the squeegee
you should you should have it before it
should have broken something two days
and not squeegee
you should have broken a lamp he kind of
sent the wrong message the best thing to
do
you're being watched from the garage if
you ever want to take revenge on
somebody in an airbnb this i mean first
of all just for legal purposes this is
for entertainment
purposes only um right this is a fun
thing to do you take a lamp
don't get a nice lamp get a lamp that
looks like it was maybe you know
you know just like a bed bath and beyond
purchase you know what i'm saying
and crack it crack it
crack it with something break it
break it but break it so that it still
stays together
okay and then and if it comes apart put
it back together in a way that it's sort
of standing
and then everything looks awesome and
then when they get home and they
reach to turn on the lamp the whole
thing falls apart and they think they
did it
yeah so okay this is to take revenge if
they do something offensive like leave a
squeegee out for you to use oh it's like
look you broke your own lamp
right yeah that spoiler alert is not
your lamp
oh my gosh i just broke this lamp that
they left for us as a gift
no you're not understanding what i'm
saying nope you break
an existing lamp of theirs in revenge
but you make them think that they did it
but you i but i bought the lamp
no no no you p you make sure that you
pick a lamp that doesn't look like it's
too expensive i thought you said buy it
from bitcoin
you need to be able to look at lamps and
decipher their values create a booby
trap something i can do
booby traps okay all right that's cool
that's cool
all right let me tell you about my dog
but first let me tell you about this mug
you put hot liquid in it and it reveals
like here you hold yours up in front of
mine
like yours has cold liquid in it and
then
you remove it and you put hot liquid in
it turns into that or turn it around
this is even cooler this side a whole
cockatree is breathing fire
put hot liquid in it so mine magic mine
simulates having hot liquid constantly
get it at mythical.com you see it on the
desk of good mythical morning if you
watch that show
or maybe you're just into this one and
you're seeing it right now for the first
time
get that design revealing
heat activated mug mythical.com
jasper come here your dog's running
around sniffing he got tired of being in
my lap
okay come here buddy i want everybody to
meet you
so this
this is jasper um today on good mythical
morning
we brought him out yeah and you've met
him you've hung out with him a little
bit he's um
he likes he likes to move this over here
so you can see him
he likes to just lay right under my my
chin
he's so sweet he's a sweetheart look at
it well he's sweet to some people
i've always been jealous of how when you
hold barbara barbara will lean her head
against your
chest like that's something jade doesn't
do but he does it and it feels so good
like this is so worth it man all of the
problems
and trials that i'm gonna tell you about
are worth it because he's a sweetheart
um we got him on
february 20th so we've had him a while
i've been kind of keeping it under wraps
because
i mean we talked about the cat on the
show and like by the time we were talk
that episode came out we had already
gotten jasper and i'm like
i don't want to go that hard with pet
episodes it's going to
people going to start rolling their eyes
but i but i had to show him off because
he's a little baby he's like a little
baby
let me see if i can pet him hey bud he
well he thinks that it's my hand nope
hey buddy yeah that's good
don't look so skeptical don't look so
skeptical he has his issues
um okay how did this begin i mean
you know when we got saka i was telling
you that christy was like well
i wanted to get a dog i didn't want to
get a cat and i'm and i'm thinking
well you know we're not going to get a
dog now of course i was wrong
she had been looking at like adoption
pictures and stuff like that
and my stipulation was if we can get a
dog
that looks like jade i like i want
another jade
but in a different color if you can if
you can show me one of those dogs
then i i'm listening but i'm not gonna
get i'm not interested in getting a dog
i'm interested in getting like a sibling
to jade
okay can now you tell me since you i
you know what you want to talk about do
you how much time do you want to spend
talking about
that particular aspect of this and have
you talked to your therapist about it
no i haven't uh we can talk about that
because i just want to know i don't have
i don't have any i haven't really
thought about it
i just i find it very linkish yeah that
was a stipulation and i was just
wondering have you thought about why
that's the case
well i'm yeah i'm so attached to jade
jade is my dog
jasper is christy's dog first of all
that that's what's
happened and i'm i'm i'm fine with that
because and jade is the queen
and she's the queen of my heart she's
what i think
some people call heart dogs you have
this one dog that this changes how you
feel about
dogs and pets in general and so yeah i
have this like
deeply rooted connection and love with
of jade that like i don't want a dog to
replace jade but i don't
i want everything i love about jade i
would insist on being another dog like
a dog that just lets you hold him or her
like a baby or like a cat everything
that
yeah the fact that jade doesn't do
anything
well no because looking the same means a
similar breed which means like
acting very similar and i mean
as you can see i mean he's just laying
here on the table
he's v he he has a very similar
temperament to jade and i assume that
like if you get
the same breed or similar breed you know
breeds are so different so like with a
long-haired miniature dots and mix you
know what your problems are like we've
dealt with the
there's a lot of problems with uh house
breaking
and training a dachshund
but you get a lot of good stuff with
like the cuddliness
and the you know just the uh just the
lay around they don't they don't have a
lot of energy
and they'll sleep with you in the bed so
it's like you take the good with the bad
but it's a known entity
it's a no no i misinterpreted it unless
you're only giving me half of the
reason because i was i thought that you
wanted the dog to
look like jade not to not it wasn't
necessarily a breathing it was like
does her face look exactly like jade's
face that's
because that's what you kept saying
that's what you were vocalizing yes
that is that's how that's what i boil it
down to in for my criteria so then
christie shows me the picture of jasper
and i was like because i'm following all
of these
miniature datsuns on instagram and
there's like these that are like peanut
butter colored and like i was like
that's what i want i want a peanut
butter colored jade
and so christie's mission apparently was
to find
uh jasper and so she showed me the
picture and i'm like
and she's like we know the the foster
mom
uh she's here in town
uh lincoln played baseball with her son
and like so we knew her years ago
and so like there was even more of a
connection we're like all right we'll
visit this dog but here's the
here's the thing we can set an
appointment for this coming saturday
we can go there as a family we can check
out jasper because it's only one picture
you don't know exactly if what they're
hiding
or what the full what the full story is
there might just be a dog that's ahead
right and you kids you got to be
prepared for that right so i said listen
we're not going to go and get attached
to this dog and then have to adopt it
and have this awkward conversation in
front of this
foster mom what we're going to do is
we're gonna check out the dog
we're gonna spend some time with it
in this girl's woman's front yard with
our masks on
and then we're gonna leave
and then when we get back in the car and
get back home we're going to
each say what we think and we're going
to give our assessment and we're going
to
we're going to we're going to vote
basically to see
if we want to adopt this dog and you can
do that in your family because you get
five people
votes actually matter that's right yeah
we have to bring
if our family votes on something we have
to bring kamala harrison to actually
break the tide
that's cool yeah i've got her on speed
dog that is cool
uh so we get there and the description
of josh before we got there was
um wait he's 11 months old
his family his parents
uh were owned by someone and they wanted
to keep him but then they couldn't
afford to get him fixed
so they ended up giving him up for
adoption because they couldn't get him
fixed
and he is super lovable this is the
description
and he will want to sleep with you
and we're like this sounds great
we wanted to sleep with us this is you
know jade's been sleeping with lincoln
because
she started waking up more often and
giving us bad night's sleep and then
when lincoln's got a bigger bed and he's
he's
not sleeping with a woman so he can just
sleep with the dog he's got a lot more
room right so our bed's empty
so i'm like but we're going to do our
plan
we're going to assess the dog then we're
going to leave um
it's funny how he's just laying on the
table this is just like he did
in good mother gomorrah like jade
doesn't do this if you put jade on the
table
i like he likes to gotta watch yourself
rubbing that belly though that's
because there's yeah yeah yes there's
this there's a penis this one's got a
wiener
the other one doesn't have a wiener oh
and look he's got a tattoo right there
look at that what is that for
i think that's where they put the the
microchip in oh
they put a little tattoo yeah yeah right
next to your wiener
that's interesting yeah that's where i'd
get it i'm thinking about it
yeah put like an arrow and then like a
like a caption or something right
caption this
so we get there and this this dog has a
cone on
and i'm like oh a cone yeah because he
had just been fixed
right so he doesn't lick his own fixture
after a few seconds i'm like well can we
take this cone off because i'm
i cannot assess this dog with a cone on
like that's not gonna happen
we put the cone back on afterward so she
takes the cone off
he is so clingy to this woman she's like
a she's a blonde
woman foster mom so just like
christie's blonde but then so then she
hands
uh jasper to christy and then he just
curls up and he's so timid
and she said he's really clingy he
follows me around everywhere he wants me
to hold him all the time
and i'm like hmm so he's got this
separation anxiety where he has to be
with her the whole time
now christie's holding him and like he's
putting his head on her neck and then
um i was like let me let me let me hold
this dog
now i was like dang this dog got some
long legs like
i mean look at the legs on this dog this
is
this is crazy and where do those do you
know where the the
leg length comes from um we think it's
we think that he is long-haired datsun
and pomeranian
so we're thinking and but we don't know
for sure pomeranians have long legs i
thought
that's what christie told me i don't
know about that
i thought i was like man part d like
he's so much taller than jade he's like
a deer but his face looks like
jade's face these are the things that
i'm thinking right again and then i hold
the dog and i'm like
oh he's so cuddly so he let you hold him
the first time he was really scared
he was like but he didn't growl at you
no no
he didn't but he definitely likes women
a lot better than guys like he's
growling at you
yeah like when i but both when we
recorded
him on gmm and also this morning like if
i just walk into the office like he's
fine with me right now he lets me touch
him he's not growling he doesn't seem
too skeptical
in fact just a second when he was lying
warming up now and i started stopped
petting him he like
he you know he hit me with his nose to
get me to keep going but if i walk into
the room
and he's just like on the floor
immediate aggression
and well fear that then turns into
aggression so i was holding him i look
over at the kids
um they're like taking him in
analyzing him but they could tell that
i'm like inspecting him
i'm inspecting him everywhere like
looking at his teeth looking at
like looking at like measuring like is
this arm too long
like his face like a dog judge that
knows nothing about dogs
lifting the tail it's like how tight is
the the took us the anal hole yeah
like um i don't know i really wasn't
looking at the tightness or anything
i don't know why but it is important i
um and then i
i looked at christy and i looked at the
kids and i said
let's get him so i couldn't
and they were like after all your
lectures about the
of what we were not going to say and not
going to do this is the classic
story i knew it was good i knew it was
going to happen that's why i told them
not to do it you can't go see the dog
you can't i mean yeah basically you have
to know that you're
you're going to bring the dog home
because you got to be like man well he's
got a cone that won't last forever
his legs are never going to get shorter
but his face his
face is so good so
we bring him home jay we want you to
meet somebody
we got somebody new we want you to meet
right here this is working title jasper
uh i've got footage of introducing him
to jade
this is your new home buddy maybe we put
jade down and i'll keep holding
jasper it's okay
that's a good girl tree yeah yeah look
you got a brother one
this is good look at the cat's tail
yeah the cat's on defense mode pumped up
the cat's like oh boy
here we go three kids
and three kids oh whatever
jade is definitely lando jasper is
lincoln
and saga is me yeah yeah
nobody likes
[Music]
so any prediction on who is who
this dog is going to love the most me
hopefully
that's a no-brainer me i'm yeah he
he completely attached to christy like
almost
literally like for the first couple of
weeks it was like he would not
leave her side he insisted on being
carried i'm like this is a problem we
gotta fix this
we eventually got him we put him in like
the place where we board
jade uh and they also did some initial
training for jade like we sent him there
for a week
to get more training so he's a lot
better in terms of being able to walk
and
sit and down and that's it
okay keep sitting sit
sit stay stay
um i'm crate training him now so that he
can get over his separation anxiety he's
he's getting a lot better in the house
um yeah
he's i mean i tweeted that i stepped in
some
some poop barefoot that was jasper from
way back you got a sneeze
you are you're allergic to him
well yeah i'm allergic dogs and cats um
um so does that mean that the people
who had him before he just didn't even
try
i don't understand yeah i don't know and
because he
he doesn't like guys i don't know if
there was something else going on but
sometimes they'll give you more of a sob
story so you'll adopt them but i think
she could tell that we were already
hooked so that was
that was pretty much the end of it i
mean he uh
he likes he and jay get along
um when you when chrissy sits down on
the couch
and jasper's gonna be right there like
curled up with christy
but then jade will go over there and
like try to get
above jasper on christy but not
aggressive from what i've seen it's just
more of like a hierarchy of positioning
and then when the cat comes in the room
they both go after saka
but they're all playing and they're
friends
jasper turns out really like saka
because well lily locked saka out of
her room by accident and and saka
couldn't
get to his litter box and he went
under the kitchen table and crapped
and it was like a juicy one yeah
cat turds on the ground this is their i
wasn't there for this they told me this
but like
i'm like god that's horrible and then
chrissy said
and when i realized that it had happened
the way i realized it is because jasper
was over there
eating it oh bad boy god
i mean we've never like jade this is the
first time the cat hasn't pooped in
the litter box we're like what the crap
are you doing and then
she's like googling and trying to figure
out what do you do when a dog eats cat
diarrhea oh gosh i don't even want to
think about this and then
he vomits good it back up in a different
spot
so now she's cleaning up cat diarrhea
over here
and then vomited dog vomit cat diarrhea
over here did you learn your lesson
and i'm like christy which one which one
smelled worse
oh gosh it turns out the vomit smell
worse i didn't know if that would make
it smell better no it gets worse sorry
you are you happy
you're just doing really good right now
yeah he's i think he's tired
he's just chilling so
you know you start to learn the the
things that make him different from jade
and one of the things is that he's a
jumper his original name was kobe
and i'm like kind of responding to that
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna we're not we
got to change that
you know it's like kobe but until 11
months old i know
i know i'm confused but i was like i was
like
i've met the man and it's a he had a
tragic
passing those kind of
cancel each other out and make it where
like i just don't i don't want to name
my dog after a
after a basketball player i'm not that
into basketball
and he doesn't jump that much on the
ride home from adopting him
i'm saying this i'm like we got to come
up with another name i'm like well
let's just go with another j name jade
was jade's name
from the adoption agency we never
changed it right and
i'm like lily's like what about jasper
because it's another j
name and it's a it's a rock it's a
gemstone
just like jasper i'm like oh i like that
like yeah and everybody else is like i
don't know about jasper i don't i don't
like the name
jasper i was like it'll grow on you it's
just a good theme
got to stick to themes here we got to
get this out of the way
by the time we get home he's got to have
a new name then we get home we're
calling him jasper and then i noticed
that like
pretty early on christy has shortened
jasper to jazzy
she's calling him jazzy so he goes from
being kobe to coming home to a new
family that calls him two different
things that are not kobe
and i called him uh long-legged peanut
butter jade
okay that's more confusing that's what i
wanted to call him
long-legged peanut butter jade sometimes
i still do i'll call him peanut butter
jade or i'll call him long like a peanut
butter
jade or i'll call him long legs i'm
aggressive aggressive he doesn't so
heavy petting going on here
um but but christy calls him jasper or
jazzy and i'm like ooh
jazzy we can call him dj jazzy jeff
after the famous dj who is
behind all the success of the fresh
prince
you know i've always been a big fan of
jazzy jeff right yeah more so than fresh
prince
i just felt like he didn't get enough
credit okay he's still doing his thing
he's he was a pioneer in the field he
wasn't just some
pop rap dj dude who was along for the
ride
no he made a he's he made a lasting
impact
on the on the world of hip-hop and still
does
i'd love to meet you jazzy jeff i named
my dog after you
but i also named him after jeff probst
okay
the best but what do you coast in the
history of television you have to
you have to land on one thing that you
call the dog though the dog
has a name jasper dj jazzy jeff probst
like you can't call your dog multiple
things uh you have to you have when we
train him we call him jasper
okay so when he is expected to do
something he is jasper
in any other circumstance as he's
something else
yeah and look you can move around i can
mop the floor with this guy he's kind of
like
a smithsonian exhibit the way you can
just kind of manipulate him
yeah i know see see and this is what i
wanted and this is what you get with
this type of dog you know it's like well
i'm just gonna stay here
i'm just gonna he's a love sponge man
and
he's got this thing we call the face
have you seen this
when he's excited so when i come home
he still barks until he realizes it's me
and then
he'll get and this is why we we think
this is a pomeranian thing unless he's
not part pomeranian and then whatever
part he is this is where this comes from
because jade doesn't do this
his he will snarl his lips
like smile and he'll smell his lips and
move his move his jaw like this and
he just when he gets excited he's doing
this
with his lips and we call it the face
and we don't like it so we always don't
do the face
well i'm going to tell you right now he
doesn't get his long legs from a
pomeranian that's what i thought that's
what a pomeranian looks like
well there's a big mane under that man
and they're like i mean this is long
legs
that's not that long these are really
long legs yeah he's something else
here look here's a pomeranian with a a
fake leg
a prosthetic wooden leg that's oh man
jasper that could be cool but
he could have be part that because his i
mean his face is that color
his face is the same as jade's you know
i mean he's definitely got some
some datsun in him long-haired datsun
but i don't know
i don't know what the other thing is but
it is i mean
doing the genetic analysis is something
that you should do it
because just because it's fun to know
because it's definitely i mean because
like a real long-haired datsun has those
really
long ears right and but both jade
and him him have shorter short years it
comes from something
yeah we'll have to figure that out but
the thing that
i've noticed in
him in the family is i think i've gone
it's expanded my well i thought i was a
dog person because of jade
but i think i was just a jade person
like
i like dogs a lot more but i've noticed
now that jasper's there and we're like
going through training again
and trying it you know trying to get him
to cooperate and learn
and understand it's like that there's a
reward associated with that that i
hadn't experienced because i didn't
train
jade that much at all and i'm not i'm
not training him that much
but even a little bit of obedience it's
very rewarding
and i start to feel like i'm moving from
being a jade lover
to actually being a dog lover
but jade will always be my number one we
started watching this show
about dogs because he started getting
into it and there's this like grooming
competition show
it's absolutely obnoxious i can't even
remember the name of it
i couldn't get through a whole episode
because the pilot episode
it was just obnoxious but the
competition was
uh these groomers were given a dog
that looked like what they called their
heart dog
which is like the first dog that like
won their heart over so for me that's
jade jade is my heart dog
i assume barbara's gonna be your heart
dog you won't really know
until you get another dog because all of
these people their heart dogs have
passed away
and now they're still they still love
dogs and they groom and stuff like that
but they have this special attachment to
this one dog that like
connected with their heart and so they
brought out these dogs that
looked like their heart dog because they
would show a picture of
this is so and so he died in 1986
and then but i'm gonna groom this dog to
look like him and then they're in tears
grooming these dogs what is this on
uh is some one of the streamers
netflix maybe i don't know um
but the thing that i couldn't help but
notice is that none of the dogs
look like they look like the heart dog
yet these people were still
emballing like doesn't he look just like
my munchkin you know and i'm like uh no
he doesn't but i think there's like some
sort of well
people blindness i mean okay so
with that i mean first of all i'm a dog
person and i've always been a dog person
um but
without a doubt connected
much more with barbara than any other
dog that i've ever had
if for no other reason than barbara's
been around for like what five
five years now but she's also your first
indoor dog no i no i had two
we we we we had merle and gypsy oh yeah
that's right but
but both of them died within a year
right you know you if you've read the
book of mythicality you know my
you know your dog curse and so
um but but but it's interesting because
i mean first of all jessie for
the entire pandemic has been
every like every couple of nights she's
on the couch
she's going through the adoption
websites like she
is big let's get a second dog and this
let me jasper he's [ __ ] he sheds more
than jade
because i'm seeing his hair go around
and that's why i'm sneezing
um here's the thing i'm not opposed
to a second dog i know for a
fact that i would like you know you see
those classic tick tocks which i think
you kind of represent the classic dad
situation which is like
a dad who's completely opposed to
getting a dog doesn't think he likes
dogs
i mean i've seen like a hundred tick
tocks where it's just like
dad's saying you're gonna have to take
care of this thing and then cut to
they play the song and it's this dad
doing what you're doing with the dog and
it's like
it's a trope at this point but yeah
that's not me
i knew that i was going to be
sickeningly in love with barbara embe
say embarrassing things to her that
sometimes my wife tweets about what i
say to barbara
barbara is my mistress she's my
girlfriend
i'm completely in love with her and i do
want another dog
and or i'm open to the
to the to the to another dog and i don't
feel like it would be this thing where
it's just like
oh this dog is replacing barbara
i'm so i'm so happy and content with
barbara
that i don't feel a need for another dog
yeah and the in the thought of like the
initial sort of like
process of training and first of all my
kids aren't going to do anything helpful
my kids not don't help at all when it
comes to this stuff right are they
saying that they also want a dog though
of course they want a dog because they
don't have to do anything except
yeah play with it yeah it wouldn't be
theirs it would be on me and jesse
to do the stuff to make it a
a good dog right and i'm just like
i don't know i'm i'm not i could easily
be broken down this is not some giant
barrier
if she went home today and there was a
dog he would i'd be super happy
so is it really jessie's not she's not
she's not i don't know if she's ready
well there's there's complicating
factors with us like i
i ca like i don't think we could have
jasper in the house because i i would be
sneezing all the time like
uh barbara is high you know hi i know
there's controversy over this but
hypoallergenic is a thing
there are dogs that are less prone to
give you allergies and they're the ones
that have hair rather than fur and i
don't know what
barbara is she's a mix of some kind but
she she doesn't
cause me to start sneezing when i hang
out with her so we would need to get a
dog
that fits in that category but yet we
would want to adopt a dog versus like go
to
a breeder so it's like it kind of
complicates and makes our decision a
little bit more difficult
but the interesting thing is is i don't
have any desire for my next dog to look
like barbara but i
am very interested in bart in the
disposition being the same
yeah once you get used to one client i
it's
it's easier you know what you're dealing
with it's also a baseline i
also i don't
have like the fact that like it takes a
lot for it takes a lot it took a lot for
jade and it takes
it takes more for jasper to like warm up
to people
and that feels like more of a project to
me yeah i don't have a lot of i don't
think jesse has a lot of capacity for a
project
dog it's more just like i mean
i love barbara but i do understand that
if barbara were to go to an airbnb where
somebody else lived
and then we forgot her and left her
there and the other family came home she
would immediately acclimate and love
them just as much as she loves us
like she is a endless supply
of attention and cuddling but it is not
ex it is not exclusive to us yeah the
thing about
i actually saw it as an advantage to to
almost a download jasper
at 11 months old to adopt him at that
age because
yeah the whole you get the cuteness of
the puppy
but at least i thought
i mean there's a lot more training that
goes into it and you know we were told
that he was housebroken
we also knew that if he's part datsun
that like
that's he's still gonna sneak off and
poop for the next three years
he looks at [ __ ] here and there yeah
that too um
but what we didn't know is that okay you
give up all of the
the puppy learning curve and you lose
the cuteness
you get more of the dog that you know
you're gonna be with
but you also get some sort of if there's
any emotional baggage or
trauma or something like that like his
separation anxiety is something that
we're dealing with and
you know if christie's like goes out in
the front yard
leaves him in the house he's like
barking and howling and
like i said i'm doing some crate
training to get him better at that and
it'll you know and
in a few months i'm sure he'll he'll be
a lot better but
um i think ultimately i'm glad that we
got a dog that was a little bit older
uh you know and christy is so attached
to him
because he's you know he needs her so
much that like she just loves it she
just
eats it up and she's like i mean she'll
say he's
you know i didn't save him he saved me
but it's like
i was and i'm like christy are you are
you doing are you doing what's best for
the dog like you're
really you cuddle him so much
that like that's not really helping with
the separation anxiety
you know it's like i mean she doesn't
take a shower with the dog
and we do get him in the crate now for
that but um
yeah for a while i was like are you
making him worse because it makes you
feel that much better that he needs you
are you saying this is like a much
housing situation or however you say
that
i don't really know what that is well
enough that's the
agreement that's when uh not to make
light of it this is a real thing that
happens
so it's when a parent purposely keeps a
child sick so the child is dependent
upon them oh my god
it's like the little girl in sixth sense
that you know
is under the bed and uh yeah it's it's a
yeah and this happens all the time it's
like this kid
is being constantly like usually they're
like poisoning the kid or doing
something to like keep the kids sick
because it creates this codependent
relationship that makes the parent feel
like they they've got some self-worth so
you think
your wife is doing that with your dog
yes she's definitely
poisoning the doctor she's the she's the
one
who took that wasn't cat [ __ ] that was
something christie made
and said was cat [ __ ] uh okay yeah it
seems like chris and i have something to
talk about tonight
okay so we got another member of the
family i don't regret it
i'm actually feeling pretty good about
it uh
and i think he's feeling good about it
you know he's he's loving everybody in
the house
and he doesn't he doesn't hate you
anymore he's just barking at you
yeah i think i mean i i think the cool
thing about
a dog like jasper is that there is
a uh
he presents a challenge he just he just
picks something off the ground
yeah he tastes a lot of things um
and it's a challenge that i'm okay with
that challenge
if it's my friend's dog you know what
i'm saying it's like
i i'm trying to get jasper to warm up to
me
and one day he will like jade used to
bark at me and now jade wants to lick me
every time i see her
um it's just the process of making that
transformation happen
is something that i don't know if i have
the patience for
for my own dog so i'm happy for you to
do the work and me to experience the
benefit i think you should do it i think
you need to get another barbara
well you know we did it's funny we went
through this phase with barbara where
i was so sure that
like i was talking seriously about
cloning barbara
you loved her that much and b and being
it's not well it wasn't that it's not
that i love her less
it was that i hadn't had a dog in a long
time
hadn't had a dog that i had connected
with to the degree that we've connected
with barbara
began to believe that maybe the dog
curse was over especially when she
got out and literally left the house and
jumped into somebody a stranger's car
and still came back to us at that point
i was like okay maybe the curse is
broken
and we started to think like what if we
always had this little white dog
we always called her barbara and that
because there are people who do this
and it was just like let's just do this
for the rest of time
you know the price of cloning a dog is
going is dropping
every year so uh and then i was like
that's crazy i mean i was like that's
crazy and also
insisting on it being barbara and
looking like barbara no no offense to
you i was like
i feel like i'm giving in to some
unhealthy tendency so i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna clone james so i was like
but i do still think about it
i'm going to you know i let go of that
and i know that i love the next dog as
much
jesse wants i just wanted jade to not
not be
threatened i didn't want a new dog to
get more attention
so i would i didn't want an upgrade
because i knew
i thought jade could pick up on that i
wanted jade to stay the queen
and she's still my dog now this is
christy's dog and jade is still the best
well the thing that jessie keeps saying
is that she doesn't want there she wants
there to be a crossover between barbara
and the next dog
and so why not begin the process now
yeah you're talking about lifespan here
yeah she's like the idea of barbara
dying
and then like going through this
grieving phase and then wait and then
finding another dog
yeah which i think there's an argument
to be made there but barbara's only you
know
five years old she's a little dog she'll
be she's gonna you know probably at
least be 12 13 maybe
significantly older i don't know i don't
know i'm sure we'll get another dog at
some point
and i'm sure i'll love it just as much
as i love barbara i mean
well maybe a little bit less a little
bit less a little bit less yeah you
never i don't think i'm ever going to
love a dog as much as jade
and i don't want to i can give you a
wreck though it's totally related you
know
i said we were watching that dog
grooming show the reason why lando got
me to watch that because he thought i'd
be into it is because
he had gotten me into um another show
that i'm recommending called
canine intervention canine intervention
it's kind of like
um dog whisperer if you're familiar with
that show but
i actually haven't watched that show
that's very much but yeah caesar show
but it's like you got problem dogs that
then
this guy i call him jace it's j-a-s
like short for jason maybe but the way
that he says his name is like
joss okay that's jazz i can't
they don't say his name enough for me to
get it straight in my head but it's this
guy from oakland who travels all around
uh california and helps with troubled
troubled dogs and like he's got this
training facility
and the way they do these these shows
now it's like all right
there's a story of these dogs and it's
like
really compelling like tears in my eyes
watching these dogs transform it's just
like i think that's the other thing that
made it click for me was like i wanted
to watch the show because i'm
trying to help train jasper but then i'm
connecting to all these dog stories and
like
weeping it's a really good show
and then at the end like with all these
reality shows
you see him back home with his family
talking about like
oh they got a newborn and then they got
these like seemingly ferocious dogs that
are just like
so well trained and all around the baby
and so you get to know their home life
and his professional life and he's just
got such a
it's called canine intervention canine
intervention but
uh it's super cool i mean the stories
are really good it's really
really well produced and uh that's my
wreck
if you're if you're into dogs uh you
should definitely watch it because
all of the stories and transformations
are
are inspirational and uh moving
all right canine intervention yeah
thanks for listening
um send me uh send my wife
links to dogs that you think that we
should adopt
and uh hashtag no not what you ask
hashtag biscuits all right we'll speak
at you next week let us know what you
think about
uh you know adopting dogs second
dog adoption experience all this stuff
if you relate to it
hashtag your biscuits next week we're
going to be
unearthing all our ideas
in traditional entertainment that were
squashed
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best